when it comes to sex we are in theory
living in wildly liberated times so you
think it would be easy to feel at ease
owning up to certain sorts of sexual
desires but for most of us the world
doesn't actually feel that generous
about fetishes it's very tricky to talk
about many of the things that turn us on
especially with our partners our
fetishes can seem deeply weird perverse
or politically incorrect so we stay
quiet and it's not only the reactions of
others which caused us anxiety we might
at times worry there's something a bit
wrong with us to get more confident we
should get philosophical about sex and
ask what your fetishes really mean why
do we even have them the good news is
that the things that turn us on are in
fact really very logical and hardly ever
simply order twisted here's how it works
every fetish of sexual obsession is
really an imagined erotic solution to a
real-world anxiety let's look at some
very common turn-ons through this theory
people in uniforms are for many of us a
major turn-on especially doctors nurses
firemen and pilots tellingly erotic
websites are full of uniforms what's
going on as so often with turn-ons
uniforms are exciting because there's an
underlying anxiety around them how many
times were belittled by people in
uniform ignored by a busy doctor made to
feel like lowly fools by the heroic
firemen intimidated by the pilot
authority is frequently hostile to us
and frustrates our desires Benz X we can
reverse this situation here uniforms can
be invited into our games the uniform
still stands for Authority but now
Authority is moved to our side paying us
exactly the right kind of attention the
pilot
far from being impossibly that controls
is thrilled to be here with us she's no
longer astern phase control of the
Airbus a380 but our collaborator and
friend the busy sensible doctor is no
longer too Stern and responsible early
interested in blood sugar levels or
kidney functions he wants us to have fun
a real world ideal is being sketched in
sex we're being invited to imagine what
or 'ti might be like if it helped rather
than hindered us reassured rather than
intimidated us sex is hinting at a
utopia where strength organization
neatness and order would be there to
make us feel more at ease more relaxed
and truer to ourselves
we're taught from a young age that we
must become independent we live in an
individualistic culture that constantly
vilifies dependence and pushes us
towards an ideal of solitary maturity
but some of us are excited by something
very different the idea of submission
being totally passive that's becoming
someone else's slave surrendering all
autonomy and just letting another person
do everything and anything to us being a
slave means that someone else will know
exactly what we should do
we'll take full responsibility we'll
take choice away from us this is
curiously nice because we're not
surrendering to any old person we're
surrendering to someone who is good and
kind and interested in our pleasure the
delight we take in surrender reveals how
hard it has always have to be in control
how much we long for someone else to
take charge fully sometimes as a relief
from the pressures of daily life in the
real world so many crucial tasks
actually depend on one's capacity not to
be daunted by suffering taking on the
masochistic role rehearses in erotic
play a fundamental idea that our being
good at suffering of being willing and
able and even at times eager to take it
to be strong because one is inviting
someone to call on a stupid bastard or a
[ __ ] it's a common feature of all
sexual fantasies they did not of course
genuinely solve the problems from which
they draw their excitement but we
shouldn't worry if the fantasy fails to
solve the problem in reality what we're
looking for here is simply a way of
explaining and sympathizing with the
desire and erotic relief we're not
generally allowed to be very bossy with
anyone in our hearts we might like to be
very dimande and insistent we might like
to enforce absolute obedience on all
those who defy us but we know how bad it
is to be too strict and too radical we
have to go gently all the time but in a
sexual game our will to dominate can be
let loose someone puts themselves in our
hands and asked that would do with them
as we please what a deep honor they
allow us to shout bully and order them
around as we otherwise never dare to
and now the commands are met only with
delight you can be as strong harsh and
insistent as you like safe in the
knowledge that the other person is going
to be just fine what can it be such a
turn-on
to do outside in a park and elevator or
the toilets behind the party again it's
to do with healy and the wound from
daily life normally we sense that we
have to be guarded and on our best
behavior out there in the elevators
public plazas shopping centers and
garage for courts of the world even
nature is seen as quite hostile a cold
dangerous place where enemies may set
upon us but in the sex games we play
outside we can prove to the public realm
is not as threatening as we supposed we
can behave as we'd like show our desires
and survive and if other people
disapprove that can't stop us we're
strong enough to disregard them public
sex civilized is the wilderness and the
lonely formal places of a city it lets
us feel more at home in the world one
can analyze almost any so-called fetish
and find similar structures an anxiety
and a corresponding solution to which an
erotic charge has become connected looks
at like this sexual scenarios can be
explained to ourselves
and crucially to other people in our
lives in fairly rational sensible terms
we can explain how our fear of being
responsible became oppressive and
therefore where we enjoy being put in a
dog collar or why we were afraid of
Authority and therefore what fun is to
be examined by a doctor in bed by
talking like this we can hope that
sexual tastes will become a little less
shameful and a little less threatening
and our erotic games in their own way a
little more logical and sane